i'm dave ponesku and i'm the executive
director of pertz which is the project
for education research at scales it's a
center at stanford university pertz
makes a variety of resources that help
educators learn about the science of
motivation and we do that in order to
help educators inspire all of their
students to learn fearlessly when
students have a growth mindset when
they're thinking in a growth mindset
they're really thinking of their
abilities as something that they can
grow something like a muscle
something that they can grow over time
by investing their effort into the right
strategies when students are thinking in
a fixed mindset um they tend to think of
their abilities as something fixed
something like eye color something they
really can't change about themselves
when students are thinking in a growth
mindset
they're doing i think two things uh that
are that are really helpful that will
ultimately help them
be more successful that'll help them be
more motivated
one is that they're viewing challenges
really as opportunities to grow their
abilities that means they're much less
likely to be discouraged
uh if they encounter something that's
challenging uh in contrast they might be
uh they might be more likely to seek out
challenges and research shows that in
fact students when students are thinking
in a growth mindset they're more likely
to seek out a more challenging work the
second piece is that they realize that
if they're really stuck on something
um then the key to doing that one might
be to persist but two uh and just as
important is to switch up the strategies
they're using maybe to seek out help
from someone and if they're thinking in
a growth mindset they're gonna be less
likely to be worried that if they need
help that means that they're that
they're not smart enough to succeed
instead they'll understand that that
their teachers and their peers are there
to help them grow and develop as
learners so through the learnstorm
activities we're really trying to arm
teachers with with a bunch of activities
um that that help that will help them
and their students learn together uh
about the the science of learning and
the science of growth mindset that will
help them engage in important kinds of
self-reflection um and different kinds
of activities that could help kind of
really reinforce those ideas um over the
course of learn storm but then also
create kind of a model a scaffold
and an approach towards self-reflection
and thinking about learning and about
growth mindset that could then be kind
of revisited throughout the year to
really reinforce these ideas
and to remind students
to keep going and keep growing